so I was fascinated by you mainly from
The Briefing notes I got given earlier
today you dropped out of school at 15
you lived in a converted ambulance you
were too poor to afford shoes you had to
eat out of bins you haven't eaten meat
for 40 years you mentioned you'd rather
dive and eat me you launched your first
wind turbine off your roof in 1996 you
set up a company ecotricity you now have
200 000 customers in the UK and you're
reputed to be worth over a hundred
million pounds that's a hell of a story
yeah that's only some of it and it's not
completely accurate but you know there's
a lot of Truth in there how long you got
well not that long we could probably do
a longer one another time you've hit the
headlines recently because of your
support for just stop oil and in
particular your financial support began
with a ten thousand pound donation a
week ago you said you would match any
other donations in a 48-hour period the
amount raised was a hundred and seventy
thousand pounds which you doubled to 340
000 pounds that's a significant chunk of
change even for a man of your wealth why
are you so committed to supporting just
some oil
well the the cause itself I mean it's a
single purpose campaign to prevent uh
further drilling for oil and gas in the
North Sea we know that it doesn't make
sense the international scientific
consensus uh is clear we can't keep
finding new forms of fossil fuels
because we can't afford to burn them if
we're going to stay within uh the Paris
one-half degree Accord which we signed
up to along with the rest of the world
in 2015. uh you know the the science is
really clear from the U.N from the ipcc
we're in danger of reaching three
degrees we have to transition from
fossil fuels rapidly and therefore
drilling for more and they'll take years
to come into into fruition just makes no
sense Pierce and so I believe that very
strongly I think the guy's doing a great
job and I'm giving them all the support
that I can so look broadly I agree with
what you've just said all right so let's
put that on the table you know when I
hear of adjustable protesters when they
outline their mission statement I find
myself nodding along my problem is with
their methodology and I want to play a
clip this is a cyclist in North London
who identified himself as a liberal and
said this to some other protesters
and you won't feel better about yourself
but you're hurting the cause you feel
better but you're hurting the course
you're hurting the green cards
so you feel good about yourself but
you're not helping
I thought it was really interesting
because he basically supported them but
doesn't support the methods they're
using and I don't and a lot of people
don't your friend Zakir starmer you've
been a big donor to the labor party and
you support him and want him to be prime
minister he doesn't support the
methodology either why are you so happy
to put hundreds of thousands of pounds
to a group who are causing a lot of
aggravation to people and don't appear
to be turning any Minds
huh well I think you know a recording of
one cyclist uh is an anecdote and a few
other people's opinions they're also
anecdotes none of that is data in if you
look uh behind the scenes
support I agree with your calls but I
agree with what he said so I don't think
he's just that guy a lot of people I
talk to have a fundamental basic
supportive view about the cause and
think we should be doing this but they
just hate what's going on now with these
protesters and when I've had a few of
them in here I've got to say some of
them have behaved like complete morons
which again doesn't help the cause
you're not a [__] you're a very very
bright guy and I think you've really you
know you've laid your own cards on the
table very firmly and dedicated yourself
to missed calls do you not think that
some of this methodology is just having
the opposite effect
well look it's definitely upsetting some
people that's what I was trying to say
but behind that there's a lot of people
that support what just stop oil are
doing because a lot of people feel
completely frustrated our governments
say the right things on the climate then
they do all the wrong things opening a
coal mine Drilling in the North Sea all
kinds of stuff maintaining the ban
onshore wind you know our fastest
cheapest cleanest form of energy it
needs no public money at all we can get
to 100 green electricity in 10 years
with no public money if the government
just enabled that but instead we have a
government pursuing old-fashioned
policies claiming that if we drill in an
old sea we can help bring energy bills
down when that's completely counter
factual we saw that from the energy
crisis last winter and of course it
flies in the teeth of the climate crisis
millions of people are frustrated by
this piece and I do understand and I do
accept that it also upsets people as
well
but watching you know watching these
guys jumping on snooker tables wrecking
everyone's fun at the world
championships and spraying their pains
around watching them trashing Gardens
that have been beautifully lovingly
produced and cared for for months by
people at the Chelsea flower show and so
on it's just vandalism it doesn't make
anybody think God that's great I must
support them it thinks I hate these
people so again I come back to you know
you are a smart guy you must know that
this is not the right way to get what
they want or what you want
well look I think with the conservative
government nothing is the right way to
get what we want in terms of the climate
crisis that we face this government are
tone deaf completely in in Hawk to
fossil fuel interest and just the old
way of doing things it's that of sheer
frustration that these people uh
behaving this way and campaign in this
way and I understand that I do
understand also that it aggravates
people but look Pierce in the background
there's a greater harm being done the
climate crisis itself killed 40 000
people in Europe last last summer when
we had those record high temperatures
this is not a one-off event it's
happening all around the world because
of freak weather there's this big thing
coming called the climate crisis driven
by fossil fuels and we absolutely can't
afford to be drilling for any more
you're a vegan have been for a very long
time and a survey came out by the United
Nations food and agriculture
organization last week I think it was
that founded a vegan diet cannot provide
some vital nutrients to 500 scientific
papers and they concluded basically you
can't get enough nutrients from
plant-based food sources which would fly
in the face of what you believe a butter
vegan diet so could it be and I put this
to you respectfully Dale that you're
just maybe wrong again
look I had a quick read of that study it
was a few weeks ago it seemed to me to
be aimed at parts of the world where
intensive agriculture is not possible
and they talked about marginal diets and
how to prevent stunting of children and
they were arguing that actually grazing
animals in those countries and eating
animals was uh was a better alternative
than vegan foods I think it was a very
specific case they were looking at
because the science is very clear take
vitamin B12 for example because animals
don't make that and 97 of all of the
vitamin B12 that we make man-made
vitamin B12 in the world is fed to
animals because they live in sheds and
they aren't exposed to the grass where
they would normally get it from it's a
complete myth that we need animals for
B12 and vegans don't get it Bear Grylls
for example Bear Grylls has come out and
renounced his vegan Faith he's gone back
to a diet of red meat blood bone marrow
and salted butter eggs fruit and honey
he says I was vegan quite a few years
ago if I broke a vegan cookbook and I
feel embarrassed about it because you
now realizes that the the future is
meaty oh what's your message to Bear is
he wrong as well
yeah look uh it's not about right or
wrong right if he feels better eating
that stuff then that's up to him uh you
know veganism plant-based living is on
the rise in our country and around the
world those people aren't wrong uh
that's a choice that people make if you
look at the cruelty of the animal
industry it's it's incredible it's off
the charts if you look at the fact that
it's the second biggest cause of the
climate crisis globally animal
agriculture that's off the charts and uh
and then look at the the impact on human
health we know that it's responsible for
some of the chronic diseases most of the
chronic diseases that affect us in older
life heart problems uh cancers uh you
know diabetes all that kind of stuff
these are scientific facts as well so
it's not about right or wrong actually
what he likes us up to him right do you
eat almonds and avocados
classic I knew that was coming right
because that's what you say to vegans
yeah do you
sometimes but listen vegans don't live
on almonds and avocados so you've
confessed as a vegan to eating avocados
and almonds and as you know they are
made from bees in California over six
week period every year and billions of
bees get habitually murdered to feed
your avocado and almond habit along with
other vegans and they often get flown or
trucked and then around the world so on
every single level eating avocados and
almonds is bad for the planet how do you
plead look I don't have a habit to eat
either of those things you ask me if I
add them and I do occasionally eat them
but almonds come from other parts of the
world and so do avocados actually most
of them come from California I do I
think you're in the business of uh of
painting pictures with extremes Pierce
and and it's not helpful
as well as a balanced diet it's more
it's more actually about principle I
don't mind people who are genuinely
principled whose Lifestyles genuinely
conform to the way that they're
preaching right and like I say I agree
with a lot of what you say but when I
hear vegans talking about this great
contribution to the planet and so on but
they all eat avocados and almonds and we
know that billions of bees get killed to
feed that and that they get flown around
the world and truck around the world and
it's all terrible for the planet I think
I'm prepared I'm I'm able to ask the
question do you not think that's
hypocritical
uh like I said I don't have a habit as
you described it I do occasionally eat
that stuff if it comes from California
or it doesn't but the bees aren't killed
are they I mean they're just used but I
think you're you're kind of dying from
the point if you eat meat and dairy
dies right everything lives and dies
everything lives in dogs
like a cow for example
cows baby cows are killed so that you
can drink cow's milk right did you know
I have no problem in did you know that
I've got no problem with animal look I
eat meat so obviously I know animals get
killed you're a vegan and you don't
agree milk I said if you drink milk if
you drink cow's milk baby cows are
killed from their mother you say bees
don't get killed did you know that well
so you have a problem you have a problem
with animals being killed
do you know do you not think it's wrong
I'm asking baby you have a problem at
Birth
as a meat eater I clearly don't have a
problem with animals being killed do you
as a vegan have a problem with animals
being killed I said
I'm talking about milk okay I'm talking
about I'm talking about bees are you
okay
are you okay with the death of a baby
cow so that you can drink its mother's
milk is that okay I eat I eat veal I
know how that's made right I eat meat so
I'm unashamed about that you're a vegan
a principal reading the question and you
don't think bees but I would put to you
that billions of bees do actually get
slaughtered every year and that's mainly
to produce avocados and almonds and
almond milk but that's a silly thing to
say
you just think the cow the calms are
more important because they're bigger
animals I think the little guys matter
too the little the little bees matter
they're living things okay
so you're okay though you haven't
answered the question are you okay with
the death of a baby cow so that you can
drink its mother's milk I I'm absolutely
absent with eating meat generally or any
consumer product that comes from animals
being killed to feed humans yeah and by
the way animals eat each other as well
so my question though for you which
remains unanswered are you okay with it
or are you wanting to take some sort of
principal stance against me
for what I eat but absolve yourself of
any of any sin yourself serious question
not at all no not at all not at all
listen I'm against the use of bees uh I
don't eat honey and stuff like that I
rarely avocados and almonds you just
asked me that favorite question of
anti-vegan presenters looking for
hypocrisy right the Big H word yeah but
you still that the direct question
shooting a baby calves in the head at
Birth so that you can drink their
mother's milk is that okay yes or no you
answer my question and I'll answer yours
yes or no you might have mine first yes
or no it's not your interview that's
mine you have it are you okay it's our
interview
your question you don't think billions
of bees get killed I say they get killed
demonstrably they get killed they don't
get killed they used they used they used
to pollinate the plants over there
that's what happens and and absolutely
but they don't get killed so now I'm
sorry okay they do die
everything dies everything dies bees
don't have a long lifespan so if that's
like a billion here baby cows and just
kill them to feed you that would not be
killing them it would just be natural
death would it
you still haven't answered my question
oh I'll come to it if you answer mine
I have
I have the bees aren't killed they're
used their kidding dies they have a
short lifespan I'm not okay with it I'm
not okay with it and I don't eat honey
for example now answer my question are
you why don't you eat honey shooting of
a baby calf at Birth so that you can do
it why don't you eat honey because
that's the reality of the dairy industry
that's never talked about why don't you
eat honey just won't answer the question
why don't you eat honey because it
involves because it involves the use of
bees but you eat almonds and avocados
sometimes they don't want them in
California and they're not all grown in
That Hideous way that's the difference
they're not all producing the Hideous
you're worried about the bees if it's to
make money but you don't care about them
if it's to make avocados and almonds you
see the problem here though and
uh the problem is you're answering the
question
no I will come to your question when you
finally get to the bottom of your own
position when come on come on you must
admit that what you're saying about it
what you're saying sound to a neutral
Observer will sound ridiculously
hypocritical
I don't see how because I've said I
don't agree with the use of bees in
agriculture I occasionally almonds and
avocados not from California and uh and
and where do they come with you the bee
shouldn't be used in that way but but
avocados
avocados come from
Spain how do you know
well how do you know anything in this
world
you've been secretly munching
Californian armors and avocados you just
feel you now feel guilty about it so
come on have we touched the bottom of
this issue yet will you answer the baby
cow question uh what is the specific
question you want answered
are you okay with the the murder of a
baby cow at Birth so that you can drink
its mother's milk I'm okay with drinking
milk yeah
no that's not the answer
baby cow there are manufacturing
standards in this country I'm okay with
the process I'm okay with the standards
I'm an unashamed meat eater I have no
complexity about any of this you're the
one that has the problem with it you
don't like people like me for munching
me but you love killing bees that's the
problem I don't have a problem
uh that's made up come on it's not made
up anyway um
on the issue
never said that you said we don't get
okay
they literally get taken down to
California and they they get killed
so that you can have your avocado they
have a rough life
not me not me piss
what do you mean not you you say yours
come from Spain there's no evidence
yours come from Spain yes
is it but you've got evidence that mine
come from California have you uh I
suspect they do because most avocados
and almonds come from California I
suspect they do yeah okay we come back
to that that's cool you show me a
Spanish rapper
California rap
um on the issue on the bigger issue of
why you came on on the issue there's a
bigger one than avocados and almonds
well actually I care I care about the
little guys in Mr B I care about the
bees right you don't it's fine I do the
baby cows well you care about them if
they only if they get killed for they
get killed for honey you care about them
if they get killed for your almost
avocados you don't so it's a it's a
weird concern that you have it only goes
halfway for them you've got to hope the
poor old B has to hope that the Boral B
has to hope that it's only honey that is
being useful to get the Dale support
right
no I didn't say it did I you said that
you can't put words in my mouth I don't
have to the great thing is it's all on
camera
yeah so we look back and we'll see that
I didn't say that you just keep making
it up I'm sure you didn't say it in
which case there's nothing to worry
about
oh right there let's move on to the
bigger issue whatever issue my final
question on that was Rowan Atkinson was
interesting this week because he came
out and said he feels duped by electric
cars and the bigger issue big picture I
guess about this whole issue of green
energy is how fast we can move to a
place where you would like to be where
it's all green and you know I think we
all had to get there obviously sooner
rather later but as he says electric
cars they're very expensive still and
the way that the battery works in
electric cars with lithium uh is
extremely bad 70 worse than petrol cars
at the start of the process with lithium
batteries in terms of greenhouse
emissions what do we do about that how
do we create green cars for example
which are affordable and aren't causing
that kind of issue in terms of the
environment from the start
well look I mean that was slightly
incoherent with respect I think what
Rowan might be saying is that there's a
lot there's a bigger carbon footprint to
make an electric car than there is to
make a petrol or diesel car that's a
fact but then in the lifetime of using
them there's a much smaller carbon
footprint from an electric car than a
petrol or diesel car so I mean that's
also a fact we already have green cars
they are electric cars and you know they
they can be driven around with no
pollution at all if you run them on
green energy our grid is currently 50
powered by Green energy so we're a long
way towards where we need to be and you
know there are a lot of things said
about electric cars from time to time
but they are super popular anybody
that's had one swears they'll never go
back to another one I know there are
problems with somewhere to charge every
now and then and that kind of stuff but
the the fundamental claim that the
electric cars aren't green is not based
on fact or science
you donated uh 1.5 million pounds to
labor but you're also in the pandemic
claimed uh three was it 309 000 pounds
of taxpayer cash for furlough do you
think that was reasonable given how
wealthy you are and given you've got all
this money to give a labor party I'm not
sure if you understand how the furlough
scheme worked uh but basically it was
put in place too yeah well it was put in
place to protect jobs during the
pandemic uh to protect jobs that were no
longer there because people couldn't go
to work it was to prevent mass
redundancies and the money paid to
companies was paid directly to staff so
no company kept any money from the
furlough scheme we didn't keep any money
from the furlough scheme we simply used
it for what it was for which was to keep
people employed
you've managed to find one and a half
million pounds to give to labor since
2014. why did you need taxpayer cash to
bail out your your staff during the
pandemic why couldn't you just diverted
some of the money you gave to labor and
use that you did say since 2014 didn't
you that 10-year period yeah maybe
there's the answer in there for you
these things weren't perfectly aligned
we weren't sat here saying oh we're just
going to bung this money to labor oh
look we could claim on the furlough
scheme that didn't happen like that but
nonetheless I go back to the fundamental
Point Pierce we didn't make any money
from that this was money made available
to all businesses in the country we pay
tax here in this country we were
entitled to use that our staff were
entitled for us to use that to save
their jobs okay there's nothing wrong
with what we do I didn't see taking that
money
pandemic nothing wrong
it's not connected it's not connected to
all the other things we spend money on
like just stop oil you know we give
money to all kinds of good causes and
it's unconnected it's just a silly
attempt a despair quite frankly listen I
put the question to you you've answered
it and that's that's the point of an
interview I'm not making a judgment at
all uh Dale good to talk to you yeah
thanks